all right so we've written this
xmlhttprequest code a few times now
let's go ahead and extract it out what
I'd like you to do is fill out the
function xhr get it does well exactly
what we've done the past couple of times
with xhrs takes in the request URI like
weapon dot JSON or BG menu dog takes in
a callback function to set the onload
function to and it takes in a type which
could be either nothing if we're
expecting text data or array buffer if
we are expecting array buffer data now
one quick note about the callbacks we're
going to create the callbacks such that
we assume that it takes the request
object as a parameter so for example you
can see our parse JSON function here
takes the xhr and then parses xhr dot
response text now we have both T parse
JSON and playsound functions here that
if passed in as callbacks will
appropriately play sound or parse JSON
as we've done before now down at the
bottom of this file we make two calls to
xhr get with weapon JSON and BG menu org
just for you to test against to make
sure that your xhr get function is
behaving properly